antes de continuar quiero asegurarme de
que comprendieron el último punto que
mencioné en el vídeo anterior dijimos
que la presión a la entrada de esta
tubería esta tasa con el agujero aquí
abajo se comporta igual que una tubería
la abertura de las tasas es la entrada y
este mini agujero es la salida del tubo
y dijimos que todo lo que está afuera
está al vacío y ya que tenemos vacío
todo alrededor la presión en este punto
de entrada de 1 es igual a ser el punto
que quiero llegar es que debido a que
tenemos un hueco aquí la presión en este
punto que llamamos presión 2 también va
a ser igual a cero esto pudo haber sido
algo confuso para ustedes ya que
pudieron pensar que a una profundidad si
por ejemplo yo considerara este punto de
aquí
esta es la misma profundidad que mi
agujero se tendría cierta presión en
dicho punto de raw por g por h lo cual
es cierto si tiene esa presión en este
punto
que justamente es lo que ocasiona que el
líquido salga por este hueco
y se toma en cuenta en la sección de
energía potencial de la ecuación la
escribimos la ecuación de berdún y
recordamos presión 1 más densidad por la
gravedad por altura 1 más densidad por
velocidad de entrada al cuadrado entre 2
es igual a la presión de salida más la
densidad por la gravedad por la altura 2
más la densidad por la velocidad de
salida al cuadrado entre 2 y ustedes
recordarán que este término este de acá
es muy cercano a cero siempre y cuando
el área de la superficie de entrada
o sea mucho mayor que el área de salida
si ustedes perforan un hueco en la presa
hoover la velocidad con la que saldría
el agua sería mucho muy lenta por lo que
podemos ignorar este término también
definimos que el agujero está a una
altura de cero así que la altura del
agujero
es igual a cero
por lo que esta parte de aquí también es
ser
simplificando nos quedan presión 1 más
densidad por gravedad por altura 1 que
ese término corresponde a la energía
potencial va a ser igual a la presión de
salida más la energía cinética de
densidad por velocidad 2 al cuadrado
entre 2
me interesa que quede muy claro este
asunto de las presiones es bastante
evidente que esta presión no es igual a
cero ya que está todo esto en el vacío
podemos ignorar este término
y la cuestión es cuál es la presión 2 si
yo dijera que la presión en el agujero
en este agujero es igual
ro por g por h donde h es
esta profundidad esto es h tendremos una
situación en la que
a densidad por la gravedad por la altura
es igual a la densidad por la gravedad
por la altura más la densidad por la
velocidad de salida al cuadrado entre 2
no digo que la presión de salida 2 es
igual a la densidad por la gravedad por
la altura estoy diciendo que estoy
aplicando una presión dentro del agujero
es exactamente lo que necesito para
compensar la presión que se encuentra a
esta profundidad y debido a esto nada
del líquido se movería se pueden
imaginar que esto es la abertura del
agujero y aquí tengo algunas partículas
del líquido que se encuentra en esta
tubería
y tenemos una presión en este punto
es densidad por gravedad por altura
pero de este otro lado tengo la presión
de salida
esta vez subíndice 2 que
es que tanta presión hay en este otro
extremo sobre el agujero y si yo estoy
diciendo que esta presión 2 es igual a
la densidad por la gravedad por la
altura
pues todas estas moléculas que se
encuentran a punto de salir no podrían
hacerlo ya que está aquí una presión que
es exactamente la misma que la que se
encuentra de este otro lado por la que
cada una de estas moléculas tendría la
misma presión por todas partes lo que
dijimos en el vídeo anterior es que la
presión en la parte externa del agujero
es cero ya que el líquido está saliendo
y es por eso que dijimos que ese término
de presión por gravedad por altura es
cero y nos queda solamente
el cambio de la energía potencial a
energía cinética que es algo con lo que
estamos familiarizados pues ya lo
habíamos visto en nuestros vídeos de
ecuaciones de cinética y de energía y ya
ha aclarado esto realizaremos un
problema en el siguiente vídeo
para comenzar ahora sí con todo claro
nos vemos pronto